my name is Michael Europe and I'm with
the environmental organization called
avataq avodart is a Greenlandic
expression and it means a hunting
bladder which were which is a part of
the old hunting equipment of the kayaks
tell me know what your concerns are
about real and embrace of the oil
industry we are worried about if the
rules we have regarding oil explorer
exploration and oil drilling are
sufficient as it is today we don't think
they are even though that that
government officials and politicians
assure us of that your minister says
he's using the Norwegian rules what
confidence does that give you well the
we know that the Norwegians have some of
the most strict rules in the world but
as far as we know there is no there's no
direct cooperation between Greenland and
Norway in how should you put it in how
to carry out those rules there is no
direct cooperation it's it's it's mostly
words and that's what worries us and why
do you think that is because it's oil
exploration
it's a huge industry and it requires a
lot of experience a lot of experienced
personnel and we don't have that in
Greenland why do you think your
government hasn't entered into a
partnership with Norway I think that the
Greenlandic situation is that we are in
in dire need of money our economy is not
very good and societies income is rather
poor so I think politicians in a real
hurry to find new income sources and
that's and and environmental concerns
are not very very popular when you are
looking for incomes well we as an
organization we just try to to try and
get some focus on that issue and hope
that that the general public will share
our concern and voice that concern to
the politicians so are we talking about
if an oil industry for this country or
when well that depends on on the outcome
of the the exploration drilling but if
the companies find oil and they find
that it is feasible to to to to get that
oil out of the ground I'm I know that
that it will be extremely hard for the
political system not to grab that chance
for for the income it generates so
what's your greatest fear
of course it's it's how this huge
industry can affect the environment
there's the risk of major oil spills in
the Arctic that will affect the ecology
of the region and then there's the the
Democratic aspect of it because when
when huge companies multinational
companies answer a small country like
Greenland they will have a huge effect
on the whole of society and that's the
two main worries we have I think I was
told by one member of government that
when Greenpeace comes here they're not
going to be able to get fuel for their
votes there seems to be a real backlash
against environmental groups can you
talk about that and how that's affecting
your work yeah environmental groups have
had a bad name in Greenland especially
after the Greenpeace campaigns against
the ceiling in in the 80s and and that
has made it hard for for Greenlandic
environmental groups to to get a voice
in greenlandic society but more and more
greenlanders are opening their eyes
about the problems the environmental
problems that that will follow the
industrialization of Greenland so I
think that this there's this an
awareness of these problems that is
getting stronger in greenlandic
societies but still skepticism against
large international NGOs like Greenpeace
for example if you could speak directly
to your government and ask advise them
or copy no caution than what we do what
would you like to say
I would like to say to them that that
they shouldn't be in such a hurry and
they should slow down a bit and make
sure that we have all the the
legislation in place and that we have
all the rules so that that we can secure
the environment in Greenland for not
just for us but for our children and the
coming generations I've only seen look
can you tell me what you have seen of
this country that has turned you into an
environmentalist describe this place
well its of course it's yeah being a
green Lander I I would hate to see some
of this this great nature getting
getting destroyed by environmental
catastrophe and and the people who live
up here are very much dependent on the
ocean and and marine mammals it's
integrated part of the daily life so if
something should happen that would
prohibit them to to to that traditional
use of the ocean it would be a major
impact in their daily lives so that's
our biggest fear that that these
industries that many people see as some
kind of Savior for the Greenlandic
economy will have a negative impact on
the environment and yeah